i could play it in uh in chess 960
but let's speed run let's see how many
levels i can i can beat
uh in the next 16 minutes so
challenge we're gonna just play quick
and
try and destroy it
or destroy her i don't know
i don't know what pronoun to use because
it's a robot but it's also based on a
human
okay it's doing weird things
um
yeah so usually the goal against like
beginners is you just want to follow
opening principles um
get your pieces into play
and then eventually create some
opportunity
i'm just going to be super aggro i want
to play g4
yeah we're gonna bring all the pieces
into play
oh she took my pawn is the queen getting
trapped i think it is
okay now it's definitely just a goner
hey eric green is from germany hey
thanks so much
lars something laura sloughlin
thanks for the bits guten
oh guten abend
and danka okay
going for oh i can go for maybe a
beautiful mate
um
i don't care about my bishop
um she's not taking it
oh it's double check and then bishop b5
oh she's i forgot she trash talks me too
she's attempting to trash talk the
the checks aren't scary until their mate
oh no my queen but she didn't take it
okay
uh that was not the best pre-move oh
that's meat
okay let's go i took
man i took more moves than i would have
wanted
okay um next pot
so this is age nine
let's play let's still play e4 we'll be
aggressive
uh we'll play a smith mora asperman
style
h6 novelty
really good chanel oh thank you
chanel like the isn't that um
is it a perfume brand or a clothing
brand
i available
then overpowering the black is very
underdeveloped
probably going to win the bishop
um let's take first
so i'm up a piece not the highest
quality game
but oh
[Music]
king is asking for trouble oh i don't
like being attacked
ditto
uh playing this move
i'm gonna fiend cuddle my king and bring
the other rook into play
and then probably go in for the kill
yeah all the pieces are aimed
there's no way black's reviving this
oh fancy move
so i can take your first and then check
and it's force mate
it's still it still says this that's not
gonna change anything
okay that was nice so that was level
that was age nine
now we move on to h10
wait why am i white every game i want to
be black i want to um
i want to play a stafford gambit wait
can i just abort i guess i'll
i'll be white again oh
oh my [ __ ] is it is she gonna play a
staffer gambit
oh she's playing a petrov this is all
theory let's play the caution gambit
knight takes f7 and chest bra had a
recent video and then d4 i think because
if takes i have queen h5
oh she knows theory i think d5 is
actually the best move
so it takes bishop here
okay i want to play e5
there we go
i am looking forward to your live stream
from masam rosain vs musk
from mars i mean it's on my bucket list
to
space travel at some point
maybe in like 20 or 30 years
h6 is actually a good move
okay um
let's preserve the bishop so g5 i'll
play bishop f2 and then
keep going for the attack
i'm going for queen here combined with
h4
okay i'm just sacking sacking more
material okay queenside castle
this actually looks really fun um
because now i have rooks aligned on the
king side
uh oh i really want a sack
i just want to make her say i don't like
being attacked
again maybe this move
oh i can take because if takes takes and
the only legal move is queen g7
oh i forgot about that move
but that's okay let's go in for the kill
i think it actually makes sense to check
first
and then take the knight do i think it
leads to something i do actually
it's going to lead to a windmill
or no this is like mass destruction
let's go
bishop h8 coming
okay that was nice i'm winning with uh
the caution gambit
oh this is my first loss since mr
schaible taught me how to play
show me how you beat me well i just did
okay do i retire like clean score or do
i play one more game
i could say new game so that was h10
and there's h15
choose okay this time i'll be black i
just want to play a stafford gambit
i think she was still she was still
playing e4 at this age
i know later in the movie she played d4
and she play the queen's gambit
okay stafford gambit time yeah this is
kind of more of a
a faster speed run type thing
oh she plays g4 she played this against
me last night too
[Music]
it's kind of an annoying line we're
gonna go into the same thing
we went into last night
um oh so queenie choose nada
um not supposed to be a grey move
the main line is queen takes g4
wondering if i can play bishop b4 here
and then
i mean white's currently down the pawn
let's do this
c3 i take it
yeah i think you sag fault
for subbing with prime
um
okay so now if i move back the problem
if i move back either way
white can play b4 attack the bishop then
b5
and attack the knight and this pawn
might be weak
but if i take then the pawn's still weak
regardless
um
let's preserve the bishop i'll play
play this move
yeah preserving the bishop allowing b5
but b5 is not happening
um
[Music]
sb5 is happening so the goal in this
position is to
like get the rook to e8 and punish white
before liking castle
i'm considering this move
kind of a fancy move
challenging the night
well maybe that didn't accomplish much
um
okay i'll play d6 if takes i i win the
queen
wow h4 is so random
okay let's take this
wow the queen is going to be lost double
attack and pin
okay this is looking very nice now
that chuck the chuck doesn't scare you
but my queen better scare you
you're going for rookie three
do i make seven more nights
or do i just go for the quick meet
okay that's tricky i could take the free
pawn but then i get mated
so let's not get mated
i'll make some luft
i always play f6
no my future knight
check check
i have to defend all my future knights
okay
oh i shouldn't have traded off my
knights that was like a
present night
no oh no
shoot dirty pre-move tricked me she
dirty
that was so dirty btw h6 isn't even a
good move
with your d4 re5 they found nf 3d6 said
six minutes i'm so sad
so much fun this isn't fun
i was gonna pre-move the rest of the
game too
oh i'm so broken can i come back from
this
this is so bad that was so dirty
okay let's try and survive
what is she saying
i'd rather her promote or provoke a
weakness rather than maybe
okay let's hold on to the pawns
ah my pawns my future knights
that's what happens when i get too
carried away
what's her readings
if this were like eight-year-old maybe i
could still survive but
[Music]
okay we're going to push a pawn
no stop wow
i'm so broken
i was so excited to make all nights
it's like you win the lottery and then
you just go broke
that was so sad i need to retire
yeah speed run failed the whole mission
is over
h6 is such a like this is a farouja
or nereditsky like dirty bullet move
where you're hoping like black premo is
one of these moves and then you just win
i could just rage end of the stream